[Music]
all right no time for the gossip
it's like an ipad air
but
smaller hey what's up mkbhd here and the
ipad mini has always been so fascinating
to me just because i always wonder who
buys them and who uses them
and what they use them for and why they
chose it over other options like i know
my dad uses one but
my sister and i got it for him as a gift
so he didn't really choose it it kind of
chose him but then i see the pilot with
an ipad mini example constantly like i
feel like that's in every ipad mini
keynote but it turns out that's fairly
common for hobby pilots which is awesome
i've already realized that as a huge fan
of the ipad pro
this isn't for me but this refresh for
2021 makes it a real option again for a
lot of people so this is my mini review
of the new 2021 ipad mini so most of
what's new here is the design refresh
which is pretty simple the unibody
aluminum there's four new colors and it
gets all the beauty of those squared off
sides which i also think make it easier
to hold and like the ipad air you drop
the home button you keep the touch id in
the form of a power button fingerprint
reader combo up top it adds usb type c
at the bottom thank you very much and
this is actually the first ipad mini
with a camera bump that now houses that
new 12 megapixel camera on the back the
only real quirk though is the volume
buttons which are now also at the top
seemed questionable at first but then
you realize this new ipad mini has
second generation apple pencil support
and that slaps right onto the side
magnetically and the pencil is literally
the size of the entire side of the
tablet so there's no room for volume
buttons over there where they usually
are so they put them on the top and i
got used to that pretty fast anyway
mostly because i find myself using it in
landscape all the time all that being
said it's the smaller form factor to
give you an 8.3 inch display that you
can hold in one hand that you can fit in
smaller bags put in smaller places and
take with you more easily these bezels
look kind of big at first but then as
soon as you start using it you quickly
realize this is about as small as bezels
on a tablet can be
to give yourself something to hold with
your fingers before you start touching
the screen so this is the same size
bezels as ipad air and ipad pro just
with a smaller screen and that screen
is
fine
it's fine it's an okay screen it's 8.3
inches like i said which is bigger than
the last generation which i think was
7.9 and it's also bigger than the galaxy
z fold 3 unfolded but it's a much better
aspect ratio it's uh closer to
widescreen but it's not an amazing
quality display so it's an lcd again
still 60 hertz same pixel density as
last year same not that great 500 nits
max brightness as the last generation i
mean it's nice that it has full p3 color
support and has true tone but generally
speaking this is uh still a pretty basic
display it's fine indoors for sure for
reading watching videos all that stuff
no problem i just wouldn't expect to be
able to use this comfortably outside in
the sun
this one's got cellular antenna lines as
you can see so it is a cellular model
that now supports 5g but just so you
know no millimeter wave 5g on the ipad
mini which honestly is not a big deal
it's useless for most people in most
places but if you were trying to use it
on one of those hot spots
many won't support it but honestly
that's probably kind of a good thing
considering the battery life probably
the worst thing about the ipad mini as
tested is the mini battery granted i was
testing it pretty hard using it full
brightness all the time about as much as
my phone and on cellular on the go but i
felt like i needed to charge it at the
end of every full day so i could get
seven eight hours of screen on time out
of it which is good it's a tablet and it
has great standby time but that's
something to keep in mind it might not
last like a week like my ipad pro
sometimes does with light use my use of
the ipad mini though is very
generalist like you know i'm scrolling
through social media lots of emails i'm
watching videos things like that
but that's the thing about the ipad mini
is i feel like so many people who are
intending to get one already have some
specific thing in mind that they want to
do with it like i bet there's someone
out there who's going to get one of
these ipad minis and they're going to
make it the home kit smart hub
light switch that they're going to put
in the wall in their house and of course
you want the smallest ipad possible to
do that you know there's probably a
student who's about to go back to school
right now who's going to get this and an
apple pencil and they're going to use
this just for note-taking all day
they're on this thing with the apple
pencil sketching taking notes writing
things down all the time and you already
know actually i do already know that
there's going to be hobbyist pilots out
there
that are going to get these ipad minis
because apparently they're very popular
as the small ipad you'd use to plot out
your flight map and it's the one that
fits comfortably in the cockpit of a
smaller airplane this is the tablet they
want to use so for me this ipad is also
fine as a super fast 500
tiny tablet and it happens to have
decent features across the board to make
it versatile the stereo speakers on
either side for listening to music or
watching videos like i do are really
good
the new 12 megapixel camera on the back
it's plenty good for a tablet it's
basically the equivalent of what's in
the ipad air and the new ultra wide
front-facing camera with center stage
works exactly as well as it does in the
ipad air which is to say
a little bit shaky but perfectly fine
for video calls and face time or zoom
and then of course that apple pencil 2.0
support which is top of the line in this
price range ties right into ios 15 and
the swipe up from the corner for quick
notes and all the benefits of having a
dedicated stylus that's so good matter
of fact it's literally running
essentially the exact same software
experience
as all the other ipads out there same
exact software as the 800 ipad pros the
multitasking the slide over windows the
app library over to the side of the home
screen it's all here and of course many
people are already very familiar with it
and it's all running on apple's absolute
latest chip the a15 with the five core
gpu which is actually better than what's
in the ipad air right now so not only
will this ipad be running very smooth
pretty much locked right at 60 hertz out
the box but also virtually guarantees
you
many years of software support and ios
updates being the latest chip the one
thing that's kind of annoying in this
software here seems to be all this
padding around the home screen icons so
the whole ui is like a little more
compressed than i remember inside of
even those bezels it just made the ipad
mini feel
really
mini sometimes with all that small text
in the widgets especially when that
weather widget is literally bigger on
the iphone than it is on the ipad mini's
home screen but as soon as you jump into
an app though then of course you take
advantage of the bigger screen i'm just
not sure what that padding is about so i
don't personally have a use case that
really fits this ipad mini so that's why
i won't be getting one
but i think those who are thinking about
getting it already know you probably
already have a thing that you're
imagining getting it for something that
you want it to do
and so for that i would encourage you to
think about whether or not the new 9th
gen baseline ipad might actually be
better for that because it's 170 bucks
cheaper and has a bigger screen
but of course it's a different type of
tablet and if you're after the mini then
yeah it's pretty good oh but it does
actually it starts at 64 gigs so maybe
you could consider that a weakness of
this
um if you want to upgrade there is only
one other spec it's the 256 gig which is
150 bucks more so at that point you're
playing in a different price range but
the baseline 64 gigs 4.99 if that's all
the storage you need this one's a go but
yeah you know it would speak to me just
selfishly and maybe a little off topic i
was imagining like an ipad
mini pro
or maybe it would be an ipad pro mini
but you know what i mean like a tablet
this size
with a nice 120 hertz display and of
course you get face id and then you get
the pro camera system on the back and
probably a bigger battery but then
you're probably looking at like two
three hundred dollars extra so that's
probably why that doesn't exist but yeah
at this price what are you
cross-shopping it with like a galaxy tab
that's out there
you could be looking at a surface go
or maybe you're looking at like the new
uh kindle that just came out with
wireless charging something like that
all these have different specific use
cases in mind this being the most
versatile of the bunch definitely worth
a look
it's the ipad mini so yeah know your use
case
that's the advice i got for you today
that's been it
thanks for watching
catch you guys in the next one
peace
[Music]